[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALPHA DOSHI: I'm very
pleased to be in this session
with hearing all the wonderful
stories from other speakers,
indeed how Google Cloud
is being utilized.
And I thought it is important
for us at Philips as a health
care sector to also implement
some of those things real life.
So indeed, this is indeed a good
learning session for me also.
I thought that would
be interesting to share
some insights.
I'm the group CIO of Philips.
We have three, four
businesses that we
are handling in personal
health, connected care,
and really trying to bring
together diagnostics imaging
and other applications to the
patient's medical industry
all together.
But more important is,
how do we work effectively
with our partners
so that we can all
make healthy living a success?
Doesn't that appeal
to each one of you?
Healthy living, right?
It's about you and I and how
we can do different things
during this journey.
So what is interesting to me
is really getting on the plate,
how are we leveraging the Cloud?
So we have something called
HealthSuite Digital Platform
that was implemented
a couple of years
back as we started thinking
through the journey overall,
that there is a full
ecosystem in the health care
sector of insurers, of
payers, of hospitals,
diagnostic centers, and,
of course, self care.
When a patient is, at
times, in the senior citizen
stage or is in the
ICU, where they do not
wish to be in the hospital.
They just want to be at home,
in the comfort zone of the home.
How can we bring the
services together?
And all of these things
prompted us to think
about what is called always on.
So you need to have access
to good health care services
and also have the ability to
give the feedback loop as such.
And that's where the entire
Cloud journey began for us,
where we said the personalized
connected services is something
that will allows for that
feedback loop to happen.
And indeed, when working
through the developments
that the Cloud providers
like Google are giving to us,
I think this is wonderful.
So if I look at it not only as
an industry domain in health
care that we are thinking
through these kinds of problems
and use cases, but also
the fact that around us,
technology is changing
significantly.
And if you see the
horizons from horizon 1
to maybe the n-th
horizon, and the chat
boards the Cloud-based ecosystem
can provide, for example,
the deep learning that
is needed in order
to give an insight
which will allow
for the technology or
the smart technology
to be really leveraged in
a health care environment
is immense.
So if I just take one of these
examples of smart technology
where AI bot services is
going to be extremely useful
is in the clinical
environment where
there is a help that is needed.
And if we are able to take up
the symptoms from a patient
and holistically
create a database that
allows that particular data to
be shared with various service
providers, physicians,
and hospitals,
and make the electronic medical
record, which is called the EMR
sector, to be a
reality, that would
be a big success for all of us.
It's really having real-time
information insights
that is needed.
We even think about
digital coaches, concepts
of digital coaches, where
we have a product which
is called Sonicare toothbrush.
I don't know how many of
you use that, but I hope--
yeah, that's one show.
Good show of hand from Tarik.
There you go.
Can I have a show of hands
for the Sonicare toothbrush?
Excellent, excellent, yes, yes.
That's what we needed, right?
So we get that feedback loop
going from the toothbrush,
whether you're doing
a good job of covering
all those ends in
your mouth or not,
and making sure that those
insights can be fed back
through the Cloud
environment, no matter
which part of the world
you are living in.
That's real life, day
to day type of changes
that we can bring to you
through these digital coaches.
Take another example.
And I love it because e-commerce
has been growing like anything.
And when you think
about e-commerce,
I always think
about, OK, we are--
say you are dealing
with an asthma patient.
And an asthma patients,
say, needs effectively
to be treated, you
need air humidifier.
So if the patient data
for the asthma patient
can be collated--
as a human being,
there are different
components that
have to be collated
from a data insight
standpoint and a
recommendation engine
to be connected through the
e-commerce online platform,
where recommendation would
be to buy an air humidifier,
or you leverage something
like an air humidifier,
then that connects the
whole solution dot.
And that's the journey
we are towards.
And I bet Cloud
providers like Google
would really be very,
very helpful to all of us.
And I'm extremely
thankful to, of course,
the platform that has been
launched, because then we
don't have to think
about constraints
from what kind of a hybrid Cloud
environment we are carrying.
I think IoT is a much-used word.
What I'd like to
introduce to you
is IoMT, which is Internet
of Medical Things.
And this whole ecosystem of
smart devices with the medical
things-- because a
medical industry--
if I consider this side
as the medical side
and this side as
the IoT side, both
have to merge and provide
the connected solution.
And so that's where,
see, the connectivity
is about not just hardware
and software design,
but actually bringing
the innovation services.
And for health care, I would
say that this is so much needed.
Our whole connected health
care system, like in an ICU
for example, how you see the
seven monitors in an ICU.
All the inputs and insights from
those seven monitors, the data
has to be connected
through real-time software
and provided to the physicians.
And so finally, I'd like to say
that the Future Health Index
findings are of great value.
We clearly see that for us to be
very high in the Future Health
Index of what Philips does,
we do see that Cloud is there
and is very much needed with
all the enhancements of AI
and machine learning
as such in order
to really give connected care,
this whole connected care
technology a successful
value-add initiative
for each one of us to leverage.
So I look forward
to this journey
with all our Cloud providers.
And thank you,
Tarik, for inviting
us to share some of our needs
in the health care industry.
And I look forward to working
with many of us together.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]